you
you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast magnetic 3d bioprinting of
cells overcoming imaging obstacles in
steroids I'm Kristina jewellers lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's events we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and 3d Griner bio
1 and MD Anderson Cancer Center and
sponsored by GE Healthcare GE
Healthcare's cutting-edge imaging
technology continue to provide amazing
depth and breadth of Investigation from
extensive data analysis to super
resolution cellular imaging GE
Healthcare allows you to analyze
interaction as they happen and gain
deeper insights into complex cellular
mechanisms for more information please
visit WWE 11 syscom forward slash cell
imaging we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the side window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button in the lower left this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
c/e button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits our speaker today is dr. glauco
our Susa dr. groucho our Susa is the
president CSO and co-founder of nano 3d
Biosciences incorporated in 3d dr. Souza
is also adjunct assistant professor at
university of texas health science
center at houston and is one of the
co-inventors of n3ds 3d cell culturing
and magnetic 3d bioprinting technology
these groundbreaking technology
have been reported in various
high-impact scientific journals
including nature nanotechnology and
nature reviews cancer for dr. Seuss's
complete bio please see lab routes comm
I will now hand over to dr. Souza for
his presentation dr. Souza Thank You
Christy a quick note i will be the only
on speaking but i'll be showing some
remarkable results from dr. Jasper 20
miles from indy answer md anderson
cancer center here in Houston quick who
is n3d we are spinoff from Rice
University in md anderson cancer center
we're located right at the heart of
Houston Medical Center and we are post
parliament partner with Greiner violin
brian is a partner to commercialize our
system of course when I give a
presentation even though I I'm preaching
to the choir I have to give a bit of
motivation of why we should do 3d cell
culturing and it's not only going to be
this slide the motivation I hope that
the results i'll be showing is a
emphasize the importance and the value
of doing 3d cell culture in this slide
is a a simplified version of the how the
drug discovery process and takes place
and we always hear that to develop a
drug it takes so long and it's always
very expensive and part of the reason
for that is because the very first step
that we do in the drug discovery process
is easy cells cultured monolayer etudie
and today there is enough results to
show that a 2d cell culture is a very
bad predictor of in vivo biology and the
next step is easy animals animals are
usually very expensive and then there
are not humans so ideally we would like
to to have to do experience
a 3g using human cells and in that what
we're doing to do so culturally bridging
the gap between vitro biology to human
biology but we're not only on bridging
the gap between in vitro in humans but
we are also trying to meet the challenge
of doing 3d cell culturing using
microscopy tools hi to put in high
content imaging which is not even not
often I easy task when dealing with 3d
cell cultures so it is right now I'm
going to be showing you a magnetic 3d
bioprinting and i'm going to show you
that we can do easily do 3d cultures we
can cocoa tree different cell types we
use flat bottom with high optical
quality surfaces we're going to i'm
going to show you high throughput 96 3 4
and 15 36 well systems will see that a
magnetically bar paint it's compatible
with high content analysis it's
compatible with confocal in wild
widefield microscopy is compatible with
the liquid handling and automation and
you can use time-dependent imaging which
is which is key so we like to call say
call ourselves the system there is a 3g
on a 2d workshop and one thing that is
important to highlight is that a
magnetic tree d bioprinting because of
many of the practical aspects that we re
enable takes full advantage of all the
amazing tools you have with ESL analyzer
6000 and in all the images that are
going to see this webinar are not
collected with yourself 6000 however I
expect if they were collected with the
each other six thousand they would be of
the same quality of that or better so
how do we do what we call to magnetic 3d
cell culturing that we
separating 23 bioprinting and meditation
we have our recording gonna show the
none of shadow is a magnetic
nanoparticle assembly made of gold and
nanoparticles iron oxide on a partisan
Potter license and the follow my scene
basically provides attaching out the
Nano products to the cells
electrostatically it's very simple you
don't require any special media you just
add another shadow to yourselves they
stick to the cell membrane which is
seldom on on air or in suspension and
then you detach your cells using
whatever method you you use in your
laboratory and you can use what we call
magnetic levitation where you put it
magnetic field on top the cells nearly
levitate off the bottom of the the
surface and aggregated at the suspense
extension and this we have a single six
in 24-hour format and we have the
bioprinting which is on the bottom right
which is uh we have the 6 24 in
high-throughput 96 384 and we're about
to launch the 15 36 and again on the
bioprinting the magnetic field is
outside of the world but on the bottom
the key for our technique it's not the
magnetic field or the nanoparticles it
fells fair interaction within the very
few minutes of our culture's you can see
in this quick movie this sells come
together Union we promote social
interaction these are shows the
importance of the disaster interaction
so what you see here we took a human
primary power block we cultured for six
hours 12 hours we fix the cells and we
stained for lemon in the red is lemonade
and the top row is long-term mobilized
and the bottom is the paralyzed so if
the top row is the do not render life
you can see the red staining on the six
hours and 12 hours which shows the
deposition of extrasolar matrix very
rapidly and this is endogenous there is
a the cells are making their own
extrasolar matrix and we post this
results in nature protocols and similar
results on a tissue engineering
one of the first results we have which
is which is key which is in its
addresses the question that people have
why should we use 3d cell culture those
3d cell culture really look like my
cells are grown in vivo so this was one
of the early experiments we did where we
took them into 29 human glioblastoma I
did a a mouse xenograft we culture us
the cells magnetically as well and we
did 2d so the last are is depressing
embedding a result of the xenograft that
took 30 days to to grow we did our
culture in the middle showed the culture
the sales coach with our system for 48
hours you know the right is the
two-dimensional so the middle row you
can see the Inca Giri staining and you
don't have to be an expert to to realize
that 3d culture by magnetic bioprinting
it's very similar to the in vivo and
that's a key result actually got up to
probably the truth publishing legend on
attack so we have generated several
models we have of course it's their
avoid models and on the bottom last year
you have five of lost cultures for 12
hours so when we bring yourself together
they can assemble very fastly to
steroids we have done co-culture models
on the top right we have glioblastoma
which is GST label co-coach with normal
human astrocyte and cherry label which
we magnetically coach it in separate
with magnetic and coach them separately
then we magnetically brought them
together and we could observe the
invasion of the glioblastoma into the
normal ostracized you know the bottom
right is a co-coach of beautiful side
stem cells which were differentiating to
a deeper side and endothelial cells and
i'll give you more detail on the dis dis
resulting in a few slides so this is
actually a very cool result from a
collaboration with the university of
houston
dr. Beulah and where we took a red heart
we digested the desired rat heart
magnetized and reassembled then after 24
hours the the culture start beating
please play movie
you
so and this is a key result because as
we when we publish our results people
are asked for function and what we just
showed it's going to critical but it is
function of the cells recovered ah and I
always showed this slide for physical
reasons we are this is a new technology
in our world in scientific world we
validate a technology by publishing and
we we placed a huge effort in publishing
in very good journals hi pack journals
and as you can see we've been fairly
successful but also I showed this
because we use none of particles and as
you probably have to money to ask what
did you learn of particles to do to the
cells and whenever tries to publish in
this in this journal that's the first
question they asked so we have published
the answers and one example I like to
give you to realize that it deliver
particles are in very small
concentrations and that it has little
segment self is the analogy is you have
a headache you take an aspirin the
headache goes away if you take 10
aspirins there's a good chance you're
going to get an ulcer is the same idea
here we use a very small amount of
nanoparticles the cells are very buoyant
so we just need a few nanoparticle to
stick to the cells we can apply the
magnetic field and they come together so
the nanoparticles are very much bio
inert to the cells and we have published
this and if you have any questions you
can contact us we can give you a white
paper with the summary of all the
results we have so this is a one of our
studies that we did with collaboration
dr. Misha Kalani here at UT health
health items in Houston where they they
wanted to do a core culture of people
side stem cells and endothelial cells in
a differentiated period of side stem
cells to generate a more aviva like
model is it your model of adipose tissue
so
but it was interesting from this study
when they first approached that they
asked which ratio sells what is the
ideal ratio to to achieve a tissue that
looks like fat in vivo and I to be
honest I didn't know I told them to use
50 50 50 / dip certain critical size 50
on the telus health and I Terry it
didn't work the cells didn't show the
morphology we want it but because we can
magnetically control the cells coming
together so we could basically titrate
or very durations of the two cell types
and for us to achieve this this the
deepest fear where red here is pretty
life in which is a marker for a deeper
side the green is da JP label
endothelial cells we had to use
ninety-five percent of preadipocytes
themselves five percent of the
endothelial cells to achieve such a
structure like this and this image here
was the cover of the tissue engineering
that we published these results so and
again the morphology is very similar of
the mythology of the in vivo tissue it's
very similar to the 3d symbol tissue now
on the right here wwat is white adipose
tissue you can see you have these motor
nuclei regions with of what we call
lipid pockets and it's very similar to
the 3d levitated culture which is very
different from the 2-d 2-d cells the
stem cells differentiated into g into g
the cells have dessert blisters as you
can see here this is all your read on
the left where you don't see that in
vivo so this was a was a great result
again we're showing that the cells coach
with our system is much more much much
more like in vivo but from the first
result this one where we we had to to
use the ninety-five percent two to five
percent nine five percent printer
political side to five percent of the to
the cells made us read the hypothesis of
what about if we bring to
other the ratio cells that is that is
the correct one for them to assemble
into give a like tissue in first to do
that we figured we you need to take in
vivo tissue so we took the whole white
adipose tissue of the direct we remove
the Depot sites we magnetize the stromal
vascular fraction cells all the cells
and we brought the cells together and
after two weeks on the bottom left here
the tissue organized clearly organized
and what do you see here in green where
the arrows are pointing to that's a cd31
staining so it seems like the tissue
organized or what it looks like
initiation of a bud vessel formation and
on the right the green is daiquiri which
is two stromal cells which is seems to
be in the right placement in the culture
so the bottom line is if you have the
right ratio cells they will organize it
into a lot of the work for us now I'm
going to shape shift gears into magnetic
3d bioprinting which is a which is a
very simple technique by printing lately
people usually think that we have some
very tasty instrumentation we can couple
this to to to automation liquid handling
short but this is a kit and basically to
do the magnetic pilot range of steroids
or ring you have you need a magnet dries
as you see here on the displayed it does
receive this displayed with magnet pins
and then you just placed your microwave
plate on top of these magnet team pins
before the space in the cells the
surface of this a microplate does need
to be sorry talent so we use the Greiner
celery talent surfaces so as you
remember from the earlier slide we
magnetize yourselves then you're going
to transfer to the micro oil plate and
when you transfer the cells to the
microplate they
go directly to the de Magna as you can
see that uh in this bottom image here so
after you you you add yourselves you
wait just 50 minutes on the magnet and
you remove your magnet and then the
cells will form destroyed so whenever
you place your your tissue play chapter
after the state's yourselves in the
incubator you don't need to have the
magnet anymore you're going to put a
magic laid back on the Magna if you want
to manipulate ins you want to change
media doing mini mr. chemistry then
you're going to place on the magnet so
the you don't want your steroids so this
is the picture of a 384-well plate you
can see all the spheroid centered a
little do well which you're showing a
little bit the very helpful feature
especially near doing a high-throughput
imaging or high contain the image as
well and I'm going to change gears here
for few slides in show some some lyrics
really exciting results from dr jack
pattillo mills laboratory at md anderson
and he using our system to coach
yourselves from patiently at the derived
you know graft and i'll show some
results are results using biopsy samples
as well so just to give a little bit of
a history on this project first dr.
Portillo mills wanted to use no matrix
models they didn't want to use machi gel
or hydrogel to generated 3d cultures
from using cells from from pdx and he
didn't sure he didn't choose our suits
on the first he choose the 5x plates
which are basically our microplates with
micro patterns on the bottom that induce
myself to form 3d culture so he he took
his TDX tumor he broke it apart he put
it on the side x plate and this was the
result he got he got the cells all this
person in the world and they didn't
really come
together he did see some of the
structures the cells to form some 3d
structures and he labeled them and he
found out that those were not cancer
cells they were those are stem cells
actually so long story short it didn't
really work so when I talked to him and
well as we saw that by adding you fell
to the patterned surfaces the cells just
stayed dispersed they don't come
together so did my suggestion was let
magnetize yourselves and use the magnet
to make sure the cells stay together and
that's what we did so but one one detail
that is important to to for me to point
out most of the the general protocol
calls for to leave the magnet on for
only 15 minutes for in case of pdx cells
it is important to lead the magnet on at
least overnight and the reason is is
that the tissue processed from from the
pdx model you're amazing you're breaking
the tissue apart keeping this magnetic
force to bring themselves together will
show that it's really key to keep
integrity of the of the samples but the
question still so he was able to take
the pdx tumor very good apart and he was
able to generate a viable culture with
our system but the questions to remain
how does he compare to the to the animal
tumor right so what we did we and this
is a diagram that shows the experiment
that was performed that is being
performed in his lab we took a pdx from
breast cancer pdx here is the tumor
right on the top in the middle and we
cut the pdx to my hat so as you go to
the left here at half with
paraffin-embedded and we characterized
using his minister chemistry on the
right the other half
we basically broke the tissue apart
magnetize the cells place the magnet and
magnetically assemble the tissue and we
did the same thing we're
paraffin-embedded and you didn't
Minister chemistry actually with our
system because we had several wells we
can do actually those depending studies
so this is the outcome on the left you
have the tumor xenograft on the right
you have the bioprinted culture as you
can see the top isn't occur during
vimentin by menton human in mouse ki KI
60 tablet is mad you can see that the
coaches from bioprinted cultures are
remarkably similar to the tumor
xenograft in this this is the type of
data people looking for to give them
confidence that moving to 3d you will
have you can have more evil like culture
so again this is a repairing to move
xenograft with two separate cultures
bioprinted from same tumor so that it's
remarkable that the similarity between
the two and this work should be
published pretty soon so and of course
when you're doing this work we always
have to to check out the cells viable
and for how long so here's just showing
that he bioprinted the cells and the
viability at day 0 a day 5 it did
increase it's not a huge doubling of the
cells but if you have handled cells from
xenograft tumors a lot of the cells
don't grow very well at all in vitro so
the fact that we could maintain
viability for five days and actually the
cells grow is uh is very relevant and
now he's actually taking a step further
he's actually taking the same tumor for
the fornication putting different
animals and comparing if there is
difference in those response
between these cells from the different
animals and this may address two
different things one is is the
heterogeneity of the original tumor and
also if there are differences between
tumors grown indifferent miles so so
here is you have to memory to a mouse
with two more a mouse a basically and
tumor from us a tumor from us p and you
can clearly see you have drug
concentration and you have viability
which is chemiluminescence you can see
that it does response between the two
tumors is different and he did for Cabo
patent HDD 6244 and he also did a are
eroding little kid and my apologies for
not pronouncing this correctly and there
was also a difference in the dose
response from this tumors this will be
published very soon and and he is
actually doing the same type of those
dependent studies interred in the mouse
to to compare so this is a key result
that should really push in the right
direction of course we've done the same
with a prostate cancer xenograft we can
take one gram of tumor we have a method
to disperse the cells basically one gram
of tumors we can extract a hundred
million cells and this gives the
thousands of wells 33 t cells at 10,000
per well and but this is on the bottom
right here is it those with response for
four different compounds using a single
384-well very good those response curves
in the duty of our system is you can put
it back on the magnet in duty meeting
history chemistry which is very hard to
do with general without a tree so coach
and that's what you see here on the on
the top right anyway we actually took a
step further where we took actually a
biopsy sample this was in collaboration
with dr. Bob Amato from it
you have health science center here in
houston we are close collaborators and
we took a bone biopsy we had enough
sample to disperse magnetize in
reassemble and get those dependence for
doxorubicin and it's a very did those
dependence curve and again we put it we
fix ourselves and put it back in the
magnet and we can stay for it came which
is a marker for these cells using a
whole mount procedure just like you're
doing the turkey and this is these
results I do believe our key for us to
move into the precision medicine area
where you can take a small piece of a
tumor biopsy and get a lot of results
with or without doing a pdx so this is
what is the the kit based looks like you
have two magnets what we call magnet
drives you have a small magnet and a
larger magnet the smaller magnets what
we call the queen team the dot printing
drive which you use to assemble you
yourself for 15 minutes and we have the
larger magnet if you want to do your
washes you want to change media you
recommend it to put on the larger name
just to make sure it's a you don't lose
their structures and the cell repellent
surface plates from from grindr alright
so now i'm going to show you more of the
traditional tricky cell culture type of
result but again these are steroids
printed from father blast it is just 12
hours and in you can see very
reproducible size and in support for me
to point that this was done with ESL
6000 and it's four times magnification
only but even though it's four times
magnification only the resolution you
get from the steroid user is remarkable
so and again this was done without
needing to to to look for the structures
in the well because they also
introverted magnetically right in the
middle before image in
one thing that people often ask is do
you have the Magnum enemy image know the
Magna is just to assemble this felt
quick or to Center them that that's all
so in the end of course these all 6,000
and provides it all the software to do
the detail analysis of your steroids you
can get area form factor average
diameter is your imaging server steroids
perimeter of the spheroid and in it's a
fairly straightforward to use and of
course we're characterizing or steroids
here's a hefty to liver cells printed in
384 you have on the right 600 cells all
the way to 20,000 cells and you can see
that a number of cells versus diameter
on the top left plot in dacula
chemiluminescence signal in the bottom
left you can see that it be very
producible inside in the very linear
signal as far as the viability signal
using software ago in this data is
publish on promega stubhub as a
collaboration with promega one area that
is true yourself culture is very
relevant is with a testy for toxicity
testing using liver cells these are
results using IPS derived hepatocytes
where we show the metabolic activity of
the 3d cultures is the cygnus can hire
then with 2g and here we just use a
refocusing to induce the metabolic
activity of the cells and we use the sip
SI from promega to detect the metabolic
activity and as you can see the red here
is the increased metabolic activity due
to the ship activity of course we also
have cardiomyocytes on other cell types
that we frequently get asked if you can
use our system to print quarter mile
sites and this is using IP arterial for
the message from CDI and we printed
5,000 5,000 10,000 cells with the 384
system and i'll show you the movie are
showing the DPD
the cells please spray movie
you
so again we printed the cell theater
then overnight they start beating and
they sustained a beating for seven days
and uh it works really well so again
feature what we do is very relevant to
high throughput and high content imaging
it's very challenging when you generate
your 3d cultures and a lot of the time
when you're generating 3d cultures in
matrix free system the spheroid or the
3d structures thing to flow to the side
as you can see at the air rather on the
left image point out the wells that
there is no steroids in their order
stuck to the side so that's data law and
as you can see you lost probably a
quarter of the cells here and this was a
collaboration with this result in
cooperation with a descript Research
Institute in Florida the group of
doctorate in spice and when you'd want
to do your image if you place the plate
back on the magnet for 30 seconds you
recover a hundred percent of your
steroids right in the middle of the
plate which make it much easier for
imaging and you don't have to scan way
style of when imaging yourselves one
aspect which you are ready mentioned
before but now is the in the context of
high throughput is corporal different
cell types and controlling the ratio of
the different the different cell types
and here we just we took a549 lung
adenocarcinoma mixed with a primary five
of last or the trachea smooth muscle we
mix them together and we let them all
reorganize and interact for 48 hours and
when you come back and look at them the
green is the hfp on the top row the
bottom is it's more muscle and you can
clearly see that you know carcinoma the
cancer cells like to stay on the outside
as the
shown in red but the important aspect we
can control destructive ratio and we can
make sure the cells are coming together
so this is a quite interesting and we
did the same now with tallow tree log
adenocarcinoma fibroblast in interesting
the this time that the fibroblast prefer
to organize on the outside and the color
3 in the inside as you can see here the
green is the father blast and the red is
the color 3 these are four different
cultures so you can see that this
process is very reproducible and again
it's just the cells organized this was
taken with the East all 6,000 and I'll
show you the confocal movie they
actually shows you through the different
nana's eastex that the tissue they did
five of us are localized on the outside
which are the green cells in just to run
remind you this is only 12 hours of
cultures so this is really fast please
play movie
you
as you can see the degree is mostly on
the outside and it did this structure is
still formed on very spherical shape as
you can see from the previous image
they're not perfect shears yet but they
definitely have the decision sugar
aspect in interterra Tris not ourselves
like to make a steroid but this did for
generating sure that a little time point
it is actually 50 characterization of
the of those cultures so on the last you
have your proverb last only culture the
middle you have the culture of the
Father Wathan callow three on the righty
color 3 and the ESL has all the
capabilities to again to measure the
detail software on the era of the
spheroid the spheroid form factor in the
primitive destroyed what is important
here is that as you can see from the
each row you see from where on the
graphs on the right is a different
steroid and they are very reproducible
from the spheroid destroyed and in this
is very important because it
demonstrates how precise the printing
processes this is again these results
from dr. Jeffrey terminals lab in here
he actually is he's coaching three
different cell types on the left you
have RFP labeled astrocytes the first
three columns on the middle they are
breast cancer from brain metastases ight
and then you have breast cancer from a
lung metastases metastases psyche and
what is interesting here the in each
column you see here you have different
cell numbers you have ten thousand cells
twenty thousand cells and thirty
thousand cells in the third row and in
the
the breath the brain the breast cancer
cells are gfp labeled as you see in the
middle stack of cells and the bottom is
to divert the rfp label cells which are
they ostracize but what is interesting
is that they did when you vote rented
the cells into steroid the brain
metastases has very different morphology
from the hmong metastasis the language
has a more of a lewis structure and in
of course the astrocyte generate a very
type structure and again this is
overnight and we can collect these
images without have just entered well
all these pictures were taken for time
magnification but there are disparities
were centered and imaging so they took a
step further they actually mixed the Big
Ed Koch coach of the other side with the
breast cancer from the been associated
in the other side with the breast cancer
from the lung metastases as you can see
here and that the morphology of the two
cockroaches is different as well as we
saw with the single cells the lung
assembly it's more loose but what is
interesting or relevant is that the
cancer this chose to organize outside of
the five of us as you can see from the
GSP label in the middle is the cells the
cancer cells are localized on the
outside and the astrocyte is called
localized in the middle and again this
are this was a all images taken with the
missile 6,000 now we're going to take a
step further we are pushing from 384 all
the results you saw until now or 384 now
we're moving into 15 36 which is a list
on the right is the image of the
prototype for what we call the magnet
drive and the zoomed in region jointed
little magnets that's a 96-well but what
is a
potent and it's a recruiting a recurring
theme oh man this presentation is as
soon as you put yourselves in the well
when they're sitting on the magnet
details coming come together within 15
minutes and as you can see you have on
the left on the left here you have image
of colon cancer and lung adenocarcinomas
part 49 and you have the left its fire
printed and the right is only when you
throw the when the cells are sealingly
well without the magnet you can see that
clearly that the cancer cells are all
assembled into all together after just
15 minutes of bio printing and again
this image the image have no magnet the
descent the plates were on the magnet
for 15 minutes on and this is we're
developing the system with a grinder bio
one and we should have we're hoping to
have it available in the next couple of
months and this are images from the 15
36 plate and again this is 10 times
magnification all the did the 3d
cultures were centered in the middle of
the well we did not have to scandal else
to capture all the decision so it's the
same period of you basically and you
have thousand cells 500 cells and 250
cells on the different roles as you can
see from the label here so it's a pretty
it's a very good very efficient way of
generating 3d cultures or using 15 36
and again this will be T is a key
technique for the high throughput
because I don't think you're going to be
able to generate the system using curve
curved surfaces which you have for 384
and 96 well especially a system that is
compatible with imaging we know 384 all
the curve it's curved surfaces are chow
ng2 to image especially when you want a
higher resolution and co focal which is
absolutely to you doing hi content in
high-throughput using cell you're going
to need it so I just want to point out
to to the D surfaces that we use are
from grindr bio one they have a wide
range of different plates flat bottom
and high optical quality now I'm going
to shift a little bit of gears to to
what I usually call this the academic
part of my presentation because it's a
new way of looking at cells so we know
by using magnetic field you can bring
the cell together very fast and by doing
that when you restart of deserving what
the cells do once you bring them
together because remember we bring the
cells together for 15 minutes then
remove it from the magnet and it's
interesting that some cells they tend to
contract as you see to the lass
themselves tend to to expand within the
very few minutes and this we're not
taking to account cell duplication cell
growth really cell sci interaction so
because we can bring yourselves together
very fact our question was can we use
this process of reassembly at some of a
homeostatic process to as a look at a
toxicity a drug effect at cell function
at viability in the key for that is
really using a real-time imaging so in
we have to approach we have the ring the
dark side we have the dot as most of the
data you've seen is using what we call
the dot which you basically destroyed
and you watch the cells contrast me
explaining but we also have a ring you
can print the ring as you can see on the
left here basically the dry where you
have a ring magnet and it can generate a
ring just like a sort of a similar to
wound healing asset and so we can
generate that very fast and you can
watch the cells to close the ring
and this is sort of a comparison of the
traditional in what we call rapid
phenotypical that we're starting to
develop and take a full capability of
the 3d bioprinting which is a being able
to observe cells early on on the tissue
assembly so on the top you have the
traditional you make as you see on the
left here you make it shared and watch
it grow and and it usually takes 10 days
to do those ethics or more so it's very
time consuming on the bottom you have
the wrapped phenotypical you assemble
the tissue for 15 minutes and within
hours you can get information from your
system and a waste we have three very
good publications on this describing the
the system and again there is that in an
observing especially if you're probing
mobility of cell cell migration
cell-cell interactions tell access
Stella matrix interaction there's
definitely valuing the day using this
approach we actually publish with
astrazeneca this activity assay which
you would treat the vascular smooth
muscle and we can follow the dilation
contraction in to the the the audience
that the cell culture in general we all
know that time is not a friend of
whoever's work myself we know that it's
always challenging long-term cell growth
because cells cells can change self can
die so if you can get early on results
in hours in a label-free mode there's I
do believe there's tremendous value and
this is a result that we we did that we
then demonstrate with you the during a
say we basically took GSP person's cell
tracker label fibroblast we use the ring
with printing to a ring and we used in
self 6,000 to follow the process of cell
phone
action please play movie and this is
you
my apology what I mean to say is that
we're gonna replay the movie a few times
so what we're really looking at is the
contraction of the rink so and that is
you can quantify that in that as as you
see on this publication this there's a
lot of good information you can get from
from this essay and again it's new ah
the reason we can do is because we can
print the cells raptly ah and again
we're trying to bridge the gap here not
only from in vitro to human biology but
also we're trying to meet the challenge
of integrating 3d cell culturing with
microscopy with high throughput and high
content and just above a few things we
learnt I hope we learned today as
reusing to doing 3d cell culturing
high-throughput with a flat-bottomed
high optic quality services 96 384 15 36
well format we can do high content
analysis and again cofo Qin wild food
microscopy again because the coaches are
magnetized we can do liquid handling and
use the liquid handling out formation by
placing the magma on the bottom just
like you you do with 2d as I showed you
the last piece of data time-dependent
imaging is key in there is tremendous
value and in we we are a 3d on a 2d
workflow because the magnetized cultures
really allows us to to use automation
and take full advantage of imagers like
the ESL analyzer 6000 from from g of
course i have to thank our corporate our
partners Griner borrow one of course g
atcc for providing us with the cells md
anderson and UT Health Science Center of
course we're small comfort
this work is not it's never done alone
as you all know we have a great
collaborators we have funding from NIH
from NFS and from from cases from the
center of the cases in the Center for
advancing a dimensional science and
space we actually have a grant from them
and we're actually our system is going
to space station in in December and what
people usually ask me is why are you
taking out 3d system through space my
cells in space are supposed to go in 3d
right for two reasons one is that cells
are although they grow in 3d space
they're very hard to manipulate so
exchanging media is the imaging it's not
simple at all so basically we're sending
magnetized cells and using the magnets
to hold the cultures in space so you can
change me they can add a compound and
facilitate the work of the astronauts
and we're actually going to go the
reverse we are actually going to use our
system to print cells in 2d as the
control the two to control that we
haven't had in space so by Trinity
magnetized cells which is the magnetic
field to basically smash the cells to
the to a membrane and force them to go
into D to actually have a control
between cells going 3d into G in space
that we don't have so this is pretty
cool you know of course i have to thank
Jeff patella Mills GE Healthcare polym
Feinberg's a deck has been great help in
getting these images and I'm open for
questions thank you very much thank you
dr. seuss are for that great
presentation while you get ready to
answer some of your questions we have
two polling questions that we would like
you to answer they will be showing up on
your screen now please answer each
question so we know how best
follow up with you Thanks now during the
question-and-answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can so
our first question is dr. seuss s our
preparation conditions vary
cell-type-specific in other words what I
expect a lot of assay development time
if I choose to use a new fella oh my
answer is is cell different cell types
require different conditions period so
if you have optimizer system for let's
say four monolayer coach which people
usually have before using 3d you should
use the same condition so the answer is
no transitioning from 2d to 3d you
shouldn't really have a you should use
the same conditions basically next
question have you done a comparison of
cell viability between the magnetized
cells and 2d cultured cells over a
lengthy period of time yes yes we have
and we we have published in different
journals and people always ask that
question we always show nanoparticles
and uh no particles and we've seen no
difference and on into these website we
actually have a white paper that
basically compile all the publish
results and in-house results that we
have showing the biocompatibility of our
nanoparticles next question for the
pilot drug screen where drugs added
after assembly of the steroids or before
and could combining these approaches be
a new way of to study drug delivery
efficacy ah my answer is depending on
the question you have you may want to to
edit your
either before during the assembly or
after the assembly because we were very
flex but that's the beauty of our system
because they did the December of the
cells is fast now you can actually get
there a lot of information by adding
your compound while they assemble or
after its assembled but you may see a
difference on the results yes which
makes sense but you can control that
very easily next question is the nano
shuttle cytotoxic and term I aspirate
the media out of wells without losing
the culture yes as I answered the first
question yet the the no no shadows are
not cytotoxic and we have a lot of
published data to show that can you
aspirate the the media without losing
your cultures yes and that's one of the
great benefits of our system because you
can put these cells back on the on the
magnet and you can do basically can you
exchange me you can refresh media to
need serum three before either compound
you can put it back on the magnet remove
your media and add your soon free media
if you want to do the minister chemistry
same thing if you want to do automation
to do your washes you can do that too
and we have user using automated washers
to to wash themselves and not losing
their selves because they're be held by
kinetic on the bottom can I perform
biological experiments such as
immunohistochemistry western blotting
qpcr biochemical assays on 3d structures
with nano shuttle yes you can do all the
all the above one thing that I tell
people is if you have a protocol from
monolayer culture that's not necessarily
the way to think about 3d culture if you
have a protocol for in vivo tissue
that's probably closer to how you should
handle your 3d cultures
because for example if you're going to
lyse ourselves it's going to be a bit
harder to to lies the cells in 3d Danny
monolayers so you may need to be a
little bit more forceful use a little
bit more stringent conditions but or
even if you want to extract more DNA or
RNA from yourselves you may need more
cells just because of the nature of the
3d cultures and that will also depend
from Celta to South Africa some cells
make very tight structures that you get
a work to break them up so but but this
is just inherited because we're working
with a cell's assembling to a tissue
configuration not as a monolayer next
question the best possible scenario for
imaging usually is when the samples are
on the coverslip after removing the
magnet do the steroids tend to settle to
the bottom or do they stay floating they
usually stay centered in place on the
bottom yes they are not attached so in
some ways they are floating but they're
not floating around let's put this way
so you can use the night because we use
cell repellent surfaces in no jail no
matrix so the cells are free on the
surface but the magnetic fields can
bring them to the center and hold them
down we have so many great questions
coming in but we only have time for one
more dr. Souza what type of throughput
is achievable realistically how fast can
you get through 1536 wells in multiple
channels with adding the extra dimension
of scanning through Z so if you let's
let's take for example 96-well and then
we'll go to do a quick mask for 15 3696
well using two callers one Feud of you
that will take about two minutes to go
through the twins 96-well so if you
extrapolate that to 15 36 it's about 32
minutes I think some of my math is right
on getting I can focus tack on 15 36
plate thank you again dr. gluco do you
have any final comments for our audience
ah no thank you very much if you have
any questions you can go to our website
in 3d bio calm and go to info and just
contact us and I'll be glad to to
address any of your questions and we
also granted by one offers demos with
our system too if you're interested
thank you dr. Glaukos to assess so much
now audience with you submitted a
question through the Q&A button and it
was not answered someone will get back
to you regarding your inquiry today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through March 29th of 2017 you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events thank you again for joining
us see you next time goodbye